hello sees these world happy holidays by
the time you're watching this it will be
Christmas which means only 341 days
until halloween so in honor of this
holiday season a couple of friends and I
decided to do a YouTube horror channel a
gift exchange in my package from how
bizarre has finally arrived so I'm going
to do a little unboxing first we got
this note do not open before x'mas we're
planning upload these videos on 25th so
I'm not really sure what you want me to
do I'm gonna have to open this one way
or another look at this the moment I cut
into that thing I just feel the sharp
pain going into my wrist no idea what is
going up oh no way you still love this
thing when i was a kid this is gonna be
great
let this be a cautionary tale to you all
ever before Christmas also be sure to
LIKE this video and comment when your
favorite holiday gift was this year do
not forget to subscribe click here to
see the president super freak knee also
be sure to subscribe to both super food
how bizarre you will not receive
Oh mistral hair so I just wanted to say
thank you for making 2015 a great year
you guys the fans are really what makes
easy's world into a thing make it
possible so thank you so much for
watching get a really great year this
year we did hello darkness final set a
bunch of short films and everyone's new
favorite thing micro [ __ ] and stick
around for 2016 because there's a lot of
big things planned for them to just a
word of caution be careful have a safe
holidays because if you're using a box
cutter to open your presents like I did
they tend to be sharp and while this may
not have been real blood this might have
been so have a safe holiday season use
caution with sharp objects so that's all
I got for you in 2015 please check to
have super freaks video you're
definitely gonna want to see what I sent
to him and I'll see you on the other
side in 2016 so I'm most cookie sure are
good